bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département tout de
suite le sommaire de votre magazine golf
c'est une surprise le thaïlandais
thongchai jay-z remporté l'open de
france de golf avec quatre coups
d'avancé sur la concurrence et devance
l'italien francesco molinari et le nord
irlandais rory mcilroy nous reviendrons
sur cette proposition avec le directeur
du golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines à paul
hermitage cyclisme le championnat
national fsgt s'est tenue samedi
dimanche son acolyte elancourt plus de
500 fois revenue de 29 départements se
sont affrontés les détails dans ce
magazine
athlétisme meeting a été organisé
mercredi soir au stade mon beau monde
versailles une centaine de sportifs a
répondu présent pour l'un des derniers
rendez vous de la saison avant les
grandes vacances autour sur cette lgv
cet événement dans cette émission
et puis à focus à suivre sur le club de
cricket de thoiry
l'open de france a livré son verdict ce
dimanche le thaïlandais thongchai jay-z
remporté l'édition du centenaire avec
quatre coups d'avancé sur la concurrence
il devance l'italien francesco molinari
le nord irlandais numéro quatre mondial
rory mcilroy retour sur la compétition
florennes parfait à pour les images une
surprise pour cette 100e édition de
l'open de france tong chaï jeddi 46 ans
remporte le tournoi avec une carte de 68
soit 11 coups sous le par
le sportif devance l'italien francesco
molinari de quatre coups le golfeur
devient par la même occasion le premier
asiatique à remporter cette compétition
depuis 1971 armes spatiales wait for me
et north wind je pense que ce week end
était vraiment spécial et c'était un
grand week-end pour moi des gaz
c'est la plus grande victoire de ma vie
et remporter cette coupe était vraiment
fantastique
croyez moi je suis vraiment ravi de sa
c'est absolument parfait parti à deux
coups de la tête la superstar de cet
open de france rory mcilroy n'a pas pu
bousculer le thaïlandais dans la
dernière journée le 4e mondial si une
carte de 71 pour terminer troisièmes à
cinq coups du leader
ça a été difficile de mettre beaucoup de
birdies les conditions n'étaient pas
excellentes pour le faire
tong chaï a joué de façon très
impressionnante et je pense que je
n'avais aucune chance de gagner les
derniers coups n'étaient pas trop mal
oh je pense que je suis dans la bonne
direction du côté des français julien
quesne et mathieu decottignies lafon
terminé 16e ex-aequo et grégory bourdy a
lui fini 25e
le chouchou du public français victor
dubuisson terminant 66e et dernière
position de l'open de france avec une
carte de plus 17
son plus mauvais score en huit éditions
au golf national
la 100e édition de l'open de france et
donc refermé ce dimanche par la victoire
surprise du thaïlandais à djezzy pour
débriefer sur résultats ainsi que les
performances défense et nous avons
rencontré aujourd'hui palermitaine le
directeur du golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines
nous sommes au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines nous avons la
chance de recevoir paul hermitage le
directeur du golf national
un jour après seulement la fin de l'open
de france de golf
bonjour bonjour paul alors j + 1 quelle
est votre analyse de cette victoire de
jay dee sur cet open de france sur ce
centenaire de l'open de france déjà sur
l'open en général c'est je pense que
c'est un succès on a eu beaucoup
beaucoup de retours on va rester très
humble avec beaucoup d'humilité mais non
je pense que c'est un succès total sur
la victoire de
j'ai dit très très beau vainqueur c'est
son histoire et
est assez unique pour une 100e qui sera
unique 47 en thaïlande est un des seuls
dans le port thaïlandais qui verse et
commencé le golf très très tard il t'a
pas très loin la balle moi je pense que
le parcours lui et lui convenait
parfaitement cette semaine parce que
vraiment il fallait rester en jeu tout
droit pas essayé d'agresser le parcours
et il a plutôt caresser le parcours et
étapes et des coûts beaucoup beaucoup
plus court que les autres mais ça lui a
beaucoup servi parce que bon il a gagné
puis il a fait une partie hier d'en
faire et c'est une vraie surprise
vraiment de le voir gagner
cette 100e édition où vous senti qu'il
pouvait peut-être remporter ce tournoi
comme vous savez moi je suis britannique
mais j'avais mon frère et mon père qui
était là et mon frère m'a dit l'année
dernière super bien joué ici tape très
bien la balle
il a fini à kigali exactement exactement
je pense qu'il pourrait être
en haut du leaderboard la fin du week
end en venant c'est pas vraiment pas
vraiment une surprise c'est toujours
quelqu'un qui fait des 16 ans où il ya
jamais de hauts et de bas et il est
toujours assez constant dans il assez
régulier oui il est très régulier et
mais bon c'est cette semaine quoi sert
semaine c'est cette semaine et c'est le
plus gros tournoi qu'il n'a jamais gagné
de sa vie il l'a dit dans ses interviews
hier soir ça c'est une grande fierté
aussi parce que ça veut dire que le
tournoi est grand et niveau de son
caractère il est commencée jeddi très
poli très sympa il était très généreux
avec avec nos équipes les jardinières
foire avec les bénévoles il a passé
beaucoup beaucoup de temps il est même
resté à l'hôtel le novotel jusqu'à tard
hier soir c'est quelqu'un de simple
tout à fait c'était son anniversaire
aussi donc c'était la fête était totale
pour lui et il a battu également rory
mcilroy le grand favori de soul on peut
le dire c'est une surprise également que
rory termine troisième non non non henry
ne peut pas gagner chaque semaine
c'est une surprise parce que je pense
que rory est venu ici avec une ambition
très forte
ça se voyait dans ses yeux ça se sentait
dans ses comportements
il n'est pas venu juste pour faire
figurez pour gagner 10 pas exactement il
est venu pour gagner
ils voulaient ces points parce qu'il y
avait énormément de points disponible
hier pour le ranking mondial et aussi
pour le ranking qualification radio
quant au riz sera dans la ryder cup
cette année aux états unis il n'y a
aucun doute il sera même promis au
deuxième du ranking
donc c'est pas nécessairement ces points
là mais il y avait avec le plateau qu'on
avait deux joueurs il y avait énormément
de points mondiale et puis il est tombé
entre 3 et 4e places je pense qu'il a
envie de revenir un deuxième voire la
première place mondiale
ça faisait six ans qui n'était pas
revenu au golf national de saint quentin
en yvelines
est-ce que ça a joué également sur ses
performances le fait qu'ils ne
connaissent pas forcément parfaitement
le parcours je pense le bon moment pour
lui de revenir
il sera un acteur fort en 2018 quand on
aura cet événement planétaire ryder cup
ici leur capuche ya cinquante ans
exactement donc je pense que tout ça
c'est pas anodin qui soit là il y avait
aussi d'autres personnalités dans le
plateau qui ont passé le cut - moins
bien joué mais qui sont aussi des
acteurs importants pour 2018 je pense
que tout ça est lié
et c'est pas une surprise qu'il revient
en 2016 deux ans avant pour checker le
parcours au niveau des français petite
déception notamment pour victor
dubuisson qui termine dernier de cet
open de france termine pas dernier parce
qu'il a quand même passé lequel est
quand même passé le k 150e joueur y en a
70 qui ont passé le cut donc on peut pas
dire dernier
oui je pense que après sa partie de
samedi et le l'effroyable dit ce qu'il a
fait au trou numéro 15
le coeur n'y était plus quoi c'est une
vraie déception de le voir terminer ce
niveau là bas je pense que les aides de
la part notamment du public face à ce
qu'il adore voilà l'attenté très très
très élevé pour victor c'est difficile
de jouer devant son propre peuple
andré guillemet il a une popularité
auprès du public qui qui existent et qui
doit ressentir avec une petite pression
donc je pense que lui il a envie de
performer
il a envie de faire quelque chose il ne
l'a pas fait il est déçu on retrouve
trois français dans le top 25
c'est une bonne chose également pour
pour l'open de france pour les golfeurs
français
oui c'est toujours bien d'avoir un
français peut être dans le top top ten
et surtout dans les deux ou trois
dernières parties de l'open de france
comme on a eu l'année dernière avec
michael lorenzo-vera en 2015 cette année
peut-être on a manqué un petit peu un
français dans les deux trois dernières
parties pour les foules qui suivait rory
est engagé a dit parce qu'il y avait de
la foule
donc je petite déception pour ça pour le
public français n'est pas au niveau des
golfeurs ils font une très bonne saison
les golfeurs français très très confiant
difficile encore une fois de jouer
devant son public
les expectations les attentes du public
sont énormes
petit clin d'oeil à mathieu qui qui
termine je crois que 17e s'il met 16e sa
seizième exil au résultat seulement son
deuxième open et puis c'est un jeune pro
qui apprend ça ça mais sans métier mais
qui a produit nous allons à présent
regarder un reportage sur le public du
golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'open de
france au plus gros rendez-vous golfique
de l'hexagone étaient organisées du
jeudi au dimanche à saint quentin en
yvelines pour cette 100e édition les
organisateurs ont accueilli plus de
60000 spectateurs sur les quatre jours
de compétition dès 8 heures du matin des
milliers de supporters étaient déjà
présents autour des greens
c'est un tournoi qui attire beaucoup de
monde donc un passionnant avec des
grands joueurs donc c'est passionnant
d'être ici je pense que c'est un tournoi
qui monte en puissance surtout avec le
la ryder cup dans deux ans je crois que
j'ai on aura de plus en plus de grands
joueurs sur l'open de france et la
vingtaine de loges de l'open de france
est également garni comme tous les ans
d'une capacité de 50 à 250 personnes les
espaces équipés de balcons accueil des
professionnels et des célébrités aussi
en a la chance d'aller voir arriver on a
la chance de stresser avec eux parce
qu'il ya quand même pas mal de dos tôt
il ya du vent et
il ya quelques gouttes de pluie mais ça
va pas durer donc dans ces moments en
fait on est content de se retrouver ici
sur le plan sportif le public peut voir
en action huit vainqueurs de majeurs 87
vainqueur sur le tour et 18 jours de
ryder cup
la super star de cette édition 2016 et
le nord irlandais rory mcilroy numéro 3
mondial au niveau de vente de
billetterie
c'est important c'est énorme + 40 %
comme comme et la moyenne et on le
ressent complètement et en le sens
aujourd'hui parce qu'il ya énormément de
monde on n'a jamais vu autant demande un
jeudi le premier jour à 8 heures ce
matin ces foules
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour une
nouvelle édition rory mcilroy pourrait
être à nouveau de la partie
ou alors paul il n'avait d'yeux que pour
ory mcilroy sur cet open de france
il y avait beaucoup de personnes qui
sont venues pour le voir et c'est normal
c'est une star mondiale mais ce qu'on a
remarqué avec le président de la
fédération française de golf dans le
charbon pendant toute l'épreuve c'est
que une star une véritable star mondiale
comme ça ça nous amène beaucoup de
jeunes et c'est ce que c'est ce qu'on en
a vraiment besoin de montrer dans le
golfe on sait qu'il ya ça frémit
et bien voilà exactement mais il y avait
énormément énormément d'enfants et ça
prouve la puissance d'une star voilà que
des yeux pour horrible tellement vite et
de 804 la tension est mais aussi les
autres français
donc
y'avait pas uniquement pour lui et sa
public chauvin ce public de l'open de
france honneur j'ai trouvé franchement
je un coup de chapeau au public français
parce que je trouvais cette année que
les comportements avaient changé je
trouvais le public beaucoup plus
respectueux que les autres années je ne
sais pas si je me trompe mais peut-être
c'est aussi une maturité qui se met en
place mais il y avait un comportement
digne d'un tournoi respectueux des
joueurs je trouve le site très propre
donc je remercie le public parce que
effectivement il ya eu il ya quelque
chose un déclic cette année le public
commence à s'habituer à la ryder cup
peut être se prépare à la ryder cup
c'est exactement mais peut-être ça c'est
que tellement on en parle de ce tournoi
ce qui nous arrive en france je le
rappelle ryder cup c'est la coupe du
monde du golf on peut le dire oui c'est
ça c'est là où c'est le plus grand
tournoi de golf qui existe sur terre
troisième événement mondial on n'arrête
pas de la rapid avait répété mais c'est
vrai terme de téléspectateurs et de
médias derrière le jeux olympiques et la
coupe du monde du foot et ça arrive à
saint quentin en yvelines en 2018 donc
on commence à en avoir l'habitude d'en
parler c'est vrai et vous êtes prêts là
deux ans de l'événement oui on est prêts
on et nous et nous et de toute façon on
va pas on va pas appeler des
organisateurs et leur dire vrai ce qu'on
peut commencer un jour plus tard il faut
qu'on soit prêt
tout est mis en oeuvre pour être prêt le
comité d'organisation france 2018
mené par pascal grizot travaillé
d'arrache-pied tous les jours sur
l'organisation assistance aux détenteurs
de droits etc
ben oui on est prêts on et dont on est
vraiment dans la phase finale de
l'organisation à l'open de france cette
année il y avait une population
importante de personnes autour de
l'organisation de la ryder cup qui
étaient là la coupe était là aussi pour
ceux qui souhaitaient se faire prendre
en photo avec
donc oui il ya un mouvement très fort et
une accélération pour arriver en
septembre 2018 est prêt merci beaucoup
pour le mitage et rendez vous à l'année
prochaine
merci à vous
les amateurs de vtt se sont réunis ce
week-end sur la colline d'elancourt le
championnat national fsgt s'est tenue
samedi et dimanche sur le site
plus de 500 coureurs venus de 29
départements se sont affrontés à romain
respini à pour le montage c'était une
grande première sur le territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines le championnat
national vtt fsgt était organisée ce
week-end sur la colline d'elancourt plus
de 500 coureurs venus de 29 départements
ont participé à cette compétition
c'est l'événement de l'année c'est le
clou de la saison et beaucoup de
coureurs c'est leur objectif project
principaux et surtout si la région
parisienne c'est paris c'est saint
quentin en yvelines
c'est l'image du vélodrome l'image de la
colline c'est une date particulière
comparé à d'autres courses sur ce site
de 52 hectares les organisateurs avaient
concocté un tracé de 5,8 km avec des
bosses des descentes et quatre côtes à
15%
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment pour un pur
vététistes certaines fois on a des
parcours pour les routiers
mais aujourd'hui il faut être fort il
faut être fort techniquement fort la
florent mothe y avoir du courage
tous les coins qui a aujourd'hui
viennent pas par hasard que toute une
préparation
spécifique pour le championnat c'est un
parcours super très technique super
roulant et avec une bonne boss faut des
bonnes gens mais un moral d'acier parce
que ça va faire mal avec les
compétiteurs on va s'envoyer labour au
niveau des résultats le vélo club est en
cours saint quentin en yvelines a brillé
la section a remporté un titre chez les
minimes avec florian richard hill un
titre chez les vétérans avec alexis
durand maxim roy y ait du vc e sky et
lui terminé deuxième chez les cadets
devant plus de 1000 spectateurs
une performance qu'il faudra renouveler
en 2010 est le championnat national vtt
fsgt s'organiser cette fois ci à côté de
brest en bretagne
coup de projecteur à présent sur un
sport peu médiatisé en france le cricket
la fédération internationale de cricket
a été créée en 1909 en france au sport
peine à se développer et ne compte que 8
200 licenciés une quarantaine de
structures dans l'hexagone dans les
yvelines un club a été créé à thoiry
pour nous parler de cette équipe locale
et de ce sport nous recevons sur ce
plateau robinho le secrétaire du château
de thoiry cricket club
bonsoir bonsoir alors avant nous parler
de votre club
est-ce que vous pouvez nous présenter ce
sport le cricket savait difficile en
validant c'est un sport il faut plutôt
le jouer pour le comprendre mais vous
connaissez sans doute de baseball de
baseball c'est la version simplifiée du
cric et crac et existe depuis plus de
500 ans
ça se joue sur gazon avec un uniforme
bon plan donc c'est un peu comme
wimbledon aujourd'hui on voit l'oeil
les gens blancs avis aux plans sur le
gazon là s'arrête la similitude avec le
tennis après donc on lance une balle une
balle très dur on le lance à 150
kilomètres à l'heure à quelqu'un qui a
une petite boîte un petit bout de bois
large comme ça et il doit taper la balle
et éviter qu'on l'éliminent parce que
derrière lui il ya trois petits poteaux
toi petit morceau de bois
si ces morceaux de bois sont écrasés par
la balle on est éliminé donc en deux
mots c'est le cricket mais c'est un peu
plus compliqué que ça donc il ya des
similitudes avec le baseball
oui le baseball en cours autour pour
marquer un point où cricket en cours 22
mètres pour marquer un point et on
revient au point de départ pour marquer
le deuxième don concours en permanence
en avant en arrière au lieu de tourner
en rond
pour le reste c'est ainsi similaire mais
après ya toute une culture de cricket
qui n'a rien à voir avec la culture
américaine donc sur ce point là il ya
quasiment aucune similitude avec le
baseball mais combien de temps dure un
match à l'horizon les vrais matchs cette
idée les matches internationaux l'été ce
match ça dure cinq jours
donc chaque journée de 11 heures du
matin jusqu'à 18h30 ce soir x 5 jours
avec une pause déjeuner qui s'appelle le
déjeuner npws theil qui s'appelle le
teil et donc céder de nombreux
britanniques
c'est très britannique et est
traditionnellement dense et les matchs
de cinq jours le match
le type de match que nous on joue et qui
est le plus populaire en angleterre et
ailleurs ça dure un peu près 5 ou 6
heures est traditionnellement ça se joue
sur un terrain au milieu d'un village à
côté du pub et on prend le teil entre
les deux parties du maintien et pourquoi
avoir créé un club de cricket à thoiry
alors pourquoi pas créer un club et
beaucoup à la fois créateur et pourquoi
créer un club donc dans les années 90
c'est parce que comme aujourd'hui il ya
beaucoup d'anglais qui est
qui était à paris des expatriés
travaillant pour les produits
d'entreprise avec des enfants des écoles
internationales
et quand on est anglais quand on est
prêts tannique
on a envie de jouer ce sport là donc il
y avait un vrai besoin est une vraie
population qui le demandaient j'avais
envie de créer une nouvelle ferveur ici
en faisant jouer tout à fait quand on
n'est pas dans son pays
c'est souvent le sport qui est un des
éléments qui manquent le plus et qui
fait la communauté en angleterre comme
comme en france
le sport c'est un moyen de rencontrer
les autres et de se sentait en entre
entre amis et du coup le club de thoiry
s'est créé dans les années 90 voilà 90
avec pourquoi at war et alors ça c'est
celle raison d'être aujourd'hui notre
club c'est le club existe parce que le
château de thouars et nous a permis de
jouer dont les jardins du château
donc c'est le cantal et quand est ce
qu'ils ont trouvé ce jeu intéressant et
qui nous ont permis d'avoir un terrain
et aujourd'hui 20 ans plus de vingt ans
après on joue toujours sur ce terrain et
il sait grèce ou au château de thoiry
que qu'on puisse exister et vous jouez
avec le comte et la comtesse
ils ont une connaissance ils ont jamais
joué mais il vient de temps en temps il
passe on est chez eux donc il
on est dans le jardin et temps en temps
il passait elle c'est avec plaisir qu'on
les accueille et il ya combien de
licenciés maintenant dans ce club
aujourd'hui on a une cinquantaine on
avait presque une centaine il est
quelques années il y avait du moment
il ya des vagues de 2
de cricket heures parce qu'il faut quand
même connaître le sport c'est pas
quelque chose qu'on apprend facilement
et donc heureusement depuis cinq ou six
ans on a trouvé pas mal de nouveaux
joueurs parce que on parle de sport
anglais à l'origine ces sports anglais
mais aujourd'hui c'est surtout un sport
de l'inde
l'inde c'est le deuxième pays le plus
peuplé au monde est là nombre d'inscrits
je serais intéressé par ça donc c'est le
deuxième sport du monde en nombre de
licenciés en grande partie par rapport à
l'année donc des expatriés d'aujourd'hui
c'est plutôt les indiens que des anglais
donc on a beaucoup d'étudiants de
d'expatriés de jeunes qui démarrent le
cas réels qui vient en france de l'inde
du pakistan du sri lanka et on a aussi
quelques anglais qui qui reste des
australiens donc c'est tout le
commonwealth britannique se retrouve à
thouaré et il ya quand même des français
et des françaises qui sont là depuis
deux ou trois générations dont elles se
sont lancées dans ce sport un grand père
qui les a appris ce sport à travers la
culture d'origine et est ce que vous le
sentiment que ce sport peut encore se
développer en france je le disais une
quarantaine de structures
il peut encore se développer aïe pays
peut se développer c'est à dire que avec
une quarantaine et
il n'y a que deux que de la marge des
fers en positif
c'est difficile à se développer parce
que c'est un sport un seuil
techniquement très complexes
donc la fédération française de cricket
et on les a soutenus à plusieurs
reprises ttc les vents oui il a été créé
dans les années 20 et puis se sont
relancés je pense dans les années 90 au
c est donc ce qu'ils aimeraient faire ce
qu'ils essayent de faire c'est
d'introduire le cricket dont les écoles
parce qu'il faut comme beaucoup de ces
sports là il faut apprendre jeune pour
comprendre les gestes et apprendre les
gestes donc mais il ya une population
adulte de plus en plus nombreux et c'est
un sport qui au niveau mondial va
peut-être existé aux jeux olympiques
prochainement dans la promotion des
langues qui va avoir une promotion
supplémentaire par rapport à ça la
question comment fait-on pour vous
rejoindre
si on veut pratiquer le cri d'amour et à
l'oeil sur notre site
touahri cricket pointe club et là vous
allez trouver toutes les informations
vous pouvez nous rejoindre et ou si vous
n'êtes pas dans cette partie des
yvelines ou ailleurs on pouvait mettre
en contact avec d'autres clubs dans les
régions merci à vous merci de passer sur
ce bateau ne manquera pas de suivre avec
attention les résultats de cricket de
thoiry l'année prochaine radio à partir
de septembre
merci injecté à présent sur le reste de
l'actualité yvelinoise
on commence cette rubrique part de
l'athlétisme meeting a été organisé à
mercredi soir au stade mon bon de
versailles une centaine de sportifs a
répondu présent pour l'un des derniers
rendez vous de la saison avant les
grandes vacances les clubs représentés à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines montigny le
chesnay but que bois d'arcy menthe et
l'organisateur versailles des athlètes
se sont affrontés à la perche javelot au
poids au saut en longueur ou encore aux
épreuves de vitesse on écoute le
secrétaire général de l'union athlétique
de versailles en général dans le crédit
ce monsieur est le meilleur moment parce
que je dirai au niveau de hauts niveaux
de l'époque si le climat théoriquement
est bon et au niveau de l'entraînement
on arrive enfin de la base
d'entraînement donc ils sont normalement
et leur maximum le niveau est très bon
il ya une centaine d'athlètes et donc
comme on a un petit peu on sait que ça
va être la dernière compétition avant la
reprise de septembre
donc je pense que tous les athlètes vont
se donner on termine ce magazine par du
football l'équipe de france qui
s'entraînent à clairefontaine dans les
yvelines s'est imposé 5 buts à 2 contre
l'islande en quarts de finale de l'euro
2016 ils affronteront l'allemagne ce
jeudi au stade vélodrome la france
va-t-elle remporté la coupe d'europe
nous avons posé la question aux
yvelinois bah moi je pencherais plutôt
pour l'allemagne mais moi la france
cette année et une bonne équipe mais
à voir oui c'est possible cette année
oui on le voit très fort le voit très
forte s'est améliorée on les voit bien
efficace
c est dur monsieur ses joueurs n'y a pas
d'origine à oui tout à fait pourquoi
parce qu'ils sont bons parce qu'ils se
sont enfin réveillés là hier soir
pendant le match et qu'eux ils ont l'air
d'avoir une bonne cohésion des clips
ouais tout à fait pas moi je crois en
eux n'y a pas de problème une chance que
oui pourquoi ils sont champions et son
champion déjà je veux qu'ils gagnent ce
jeu qui gagne avec la france allez la
france ce sera le mot de la fin dans ce
magazine merci de l'avoir suivi
n'oubliez pas que vous pouvez retrouver
cette émission en replay sur notre site
internet et sur youtube très belle
soirée sur tv fil 78